the left decries anti-asian hate but
only when they believe the culprit is
whiteness and left racist vision of
equity infuses america's government and
boardrooms i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so the news of the day
remains
this horrific shooting in atlanta
according to usa today authorities on
wednesday said a gunman suspected of
killing eight people six of whom were
asian women and three spas may have
frequented the business but that it was
too early to determine if the shootings
would in fact be considered a hate crime
at least four of the victims of the
atlanta area spas shootings were women
of korean descent south korea's foreign
ministry said on wednesday
two others were of asian descent police
said atlanta police chief rodney bryant
said it was too soon in the
investigation to say
whether the shootings were in fact a hey
crime said we're just not there yet the
suspect whose name we won't mention
because you don't mention mass shooting
suspects names to give them
the attention that they seek here was
charged with eight counts of murder
wednesday
in all three shootings four of the
counts against this person are related
to shootings at the two spots in atlanta
the other four related to shootings at a
spa
in cherokee county the shooter has not
been charged with a hate crime a
specific charge authorities must prove
a crime was committed on the basis of
race colored gender disability or sexual
orientation he purchased a firearm on
tuesday the day of the attacks
from sporting goods store in cherokee
county the shop's attorney said the
clients are fully cooperating
with the police according to the
cherokee county sheriff frank reynolds
he said that the shooter told
authorities his actions were not
racially motivated
and that in fact he had a sex addiction
all three spas
that were shot up were listed on an
erotic review site that allows users to
search for and review illicit
massage parlors the site is the most
popular of its kind where buyers who
call themselves hobbyists or mongers
looking for sex
go to find and share information
according to a study by polaris a
non-profit group that operates the
national
human trafficking line aromatherapy spa
and gold spa both in atlanta have around
100 reviews many recents
a review for gold spot march 9th
indicated it was full service as did a
similar review
from five days prior young's asian
massage in akworth georgia has 39
reviews on this particular site the
latest
posted in february apparently there is
no criminal record for the shooter
in 2019 the shooter's parents reported
him missing when he ran off with his
girlfriend
authorities note in the 2019 report his
parents said that the shooter was not
suicidal didn't take any medication and
had
no mental illness okay so here is the
sheriff
discussing what was the possible motive
here the sheriff says that this may have
been
about the shooter having a sex addiction
and then wanting to
shoot sex workers as a result of his sex
addiction and guilt over his sex
addiction which of course is a
tremendous act of evil
but he says we are not sure at this
point whether this in fact is a hate
crime or not whether this was targeting
asians or whether he was doing
this act of evil out of some other
motivation
he made indication indicators that uh
he has uh some some issues uh
potentially
uh sexual addiction and um uh
may have frequented some of these places
in the past
the working theory is a sexual addiction
issue rather than a
racial profile uh during our interviews
uh we asked that specific question and
uh and
that did not appear to be the motive
okay and
this of course is not what our media
wanted to hear what our media
wanted to hear is that this was just the
latest outgrowth of a spate of
anti-asian hate that has swept the
nation
in 2020 2021 and since the outbreak of
the pandemic there's been a spike in
anti-asian hate crime
but what the media would like to say is
that this is because of president trump
and this is because of
white hate for asian americans the
reality is that the media do not care
about anti-asian hate they've not cared
about anti-asian hate for a very long
time they only care about anti-asian
hate
as just another way of ripping
quote-unquote whiteness or whipping
ripping trump
the fact of the matter is unfortunately
all anti-asian hate all racism is bad
but only certain types of racism
are bad according to the left now all
animals are equal but only some animals
are more equal than others
that's the way that it works in
leftville so when it comes to the left
in anti-asian hate
um they only care about anti-asian hate
when it can be attributed to
whiteness or to a broader white
supremacy or to something else
and they don't need evidence to actually
show this okay there's an actual cnn
headline i'm not kidding
there's a cnn headline today that is so
beyond the pale
that it just demonstrates exactly where
the media's head is at when it comes to
this thing
now again we don't know the motive in in
this particular case yet
it could very well be that this guy was
driven by anti-asian animus it could
very well be that but that's not what
the police are saying right now
joe biden still having a a
tiny portion of his brain left
functional said this yesterday he said
i'm gonna wait to attribute motive his
party didn't say this he was the
president of the united states yesterday
which actually saying a responsible
thing good for him
the investigation is ongoing and the
question of motivation
is still to be determined but
whatever the motivation here i know that
asian americans are
in very uh very concerned
but i'm making no connection at this
moment for the motivation of what the
of the killer i'm waiting for an answer
from
as the investigation proceeds from the
fbi
so honestly good for good for biden good
for credit where credit is due president
biden saying that he's going to wait for
more information is what a responsible
politician would do
or what a responsible media would do
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
responsible politicians on the left and
we have apparently no one who is
responsible
in our establishment media this is an
actual headline from cnn
white supremacy and hate are haunting
asian americans
and then underneath is the analysis it's
immaterial
whether the accused killer in the
atlanta spa shootings admits to a racist
motivation
asian americans have been living in fear
for months it's immaterial
really so the facts are immaterial is
the way that you're putting this
it's completely immaterial what actually
happened in this particular case we have
a narrative and the narrative must be
pushed and the narrative is of course
that the uptick in racial crimes against
asian americans are being driven
specifically by white supremacy
and they are being driven by whiteness
more broadly now understand when the
left says white supremacy the left
doesn't actually mean
actual honest to god white supremacists
who are overtly racist and believe in
the supremacy of the white rice they
don't mean that they mean ibrahim x
candy type
whiteness or immax candy type white
supremacy in that you do not agree with
the
baseline reality that the left wishes to
purport and therefore you are somehow
broadly guilty of crimes in which you
yourself did not engage
that is why they don't need actual
evidence that this particular shooter
was actually a white supremacist to
attribute his actions to white supremacy
because you see white supremacy is
broader than just being a white
supremacist
right in order normally for a normal
person to attribute a shooting crime to
white supremacist the person has to be a
white supremacist
like for example when there was a a
shooting at the west valley jcc when i
was a kid
it was done by an actual honest-to-god
white supremacist and you could actually
name the guy
you could look at the groups he was a
member of the tree of life synagogue
shooting right that was an actual white
supremacist crime and you could tell
because the guy was an actual white
supremacist
right same thing the chabad of poway
shooting in the last couple of years
right you can tell when people are over
white supremacists usually they're
pretty obvious and clear about it but
the left wants to attribute this more
broadly to the problem
of whiteness not just white supremacists
but white supremacy which they say means
the system as a whole the system as a
whole is responsible
and particularly white people are
responsible for this
so they broadened out the terminology
here now let's just be clear
on this we don't know the motive here
and also if we are going to examine the
uptick
in anti-asian hate crime we might
actually at some point you know want to
actually look at like these stats we
might want to look at who is
who is actually purveying crime against
asians in the united states
so the most recent statistics that i
have seen where we actually have
stats broken down by the by the race of
the offender
right hate crime stats broken down by
the race of the offender this is from
the bureau of justice to
six circa 2018 so unless this wildly
changed in 2020 which seems somewhat
unlikely to me
could happen but i think it's somewhat
unlikely unless that wildly changed
this is a fairly good indicator of
exactly who's committing crimes against
asian americans
in the united states hate crimes against
asian americans and when people say well
we
data is not racist data is just data so
if you don't like the data
that would be your problem okay so the
bureau of justice statistics 2018
we're now looking in the line that says
victim race ethnicity asian
right you're a victim of an anti-asian
hate crime so according
to the bureau of justice statistics
there were 182
230 violent incidents against asian
americans
on the basis of race right by victim and
offender race or ethnicity percent of
violence incidents by victim and
offender race
or ethnicity the offenders race or
ethnicity against asians
the offenders race or ethnicity 24.1
percent
of the people who victimized nations
were asian
seven percent of people who victimized
asians were hispanic
24.1 percent of people who victimized
asians were white
27.5 percent of people who victimized
asians were black
okay this is according to the percent of
violent incidents by victim and offender
status
right that is that is the the latest
stat that is available to me showing
who's perpetrating violence against
asians in the united states
and actually those stats are kind of
stunning because virtually every other
racial group
the vast majority of people who commit
crimes against a racial group are
members of the young racial group right
if you're looking at people who are
victims
if you're looking at offenders against
white americans 62.1 percent
of all white americans who are
victimized by violent incidents are
victimized by other white people
in the black community something like
70.3
same table 70.3 of all crimes violent
crimes committed against black americans
are committed by black people
among hispanic americans 45.4 of all
crimes committed against hispanic people
are committed by hispanic people but
among asians
but among asians asian americans are
only
they rank like third in terms of the
racial groups that victimizations
which is really weird and number one is
black americans victimizing asian
americans according to
the 2018 bureau of justice statistics so
normally what you'd want to do
when you look at a rise in anti-asian
hate crime is look at the source of the
anti-asian hate crime
but the problem is our media don't
actually want to do that because if our
media do that what they might discover
is that the source of a lot of the
anti-asian hate crimes
are actually coming from another
minority group namely the black
community the same thing has happened
with anti-semitic hate crimes in the
united states
a huge number of anti-semitic hate
crimes in the united states are not
attributable to white supremacists
a huge percentage of anti-jewish hate
crimes in the united states are
attributable to black americans
and frankly are very often not charged
as such because it's uncomfortable for
prosecutors
to point out that black americans are
capable of committing hate crimes
and we've seen these hate crimes occur
right we've seen a lot of these hate
crimes actually occur on tape for
example
in san jose there was a pretty terrible
incident that was caught on tape
just a couple of weeks ago in which a
black perpetrator
just started beating the hell
essentially out of an asian person
there's an anti-asian hate crime in
seattle not all that long ago
in which you really had to dig to get to
the the point where you actually found
the race of the perpetrator
but it turns out that the race of the
perpetrator the perpetrator happened to
be a black person
okay the media will not mention the race
of the perpetrator in these cases
if the perpetrator happens to be black
now here's my rule if you are
perpetrating a hate crime i do not care
about your race you are doing something
evil
but the media do deeply care about the
race because if they suggest
that maybe anti-asian hate crime should
always be treated the same
well what this would mean is that we
would have to look at racism outside of
white
americans and what they want to do is
say that whiteness writ large is really
the problem here
they want to say whiteness writ large is
really the problem now here's the thing
anti-asian hate crimes in the united
states apparently year on year
rose about 150 in major u.s cities this
is according to
cbs news a new study based on police
department statistics across
major united states cities found a
nearly 150 surge in anti-asian hate
crimes in 2020 while overall hate crimes
fell
by seven percent the numbers reflect a
growing trend of discrimination against
asian americans during the coronavirus
pandemic now again there are some
confounds here it's difficult to tell
whether this is because americans are
angry at asian people
on the basis of covet or whether
it just turns out that a lot of people
are home and a lot of people don't have
jobs
and this results in an increase in
violence in particular areas of
particular cities
it's difficult to attribute coveted
motivation to all of this and i've yet
to
i'm not really aware that there's been a
study that spends on linking it
it's possible i'm just not aware there's
a study that's explicitly linked this
stuff
the report released this week by the
center for the study of hate and
extremism at csu san bernardino examined
hate crimes in 16 of america's largest
cities
and found the first bikes rose alongside
covet 19 cases in march and april
new york city saw the highest jump
rising from 3 to 28.
boston and la followed with increases
from 6-14 and 7-15
respectively hate incidents defined by
the doj as acts of prejudice that aren't
crimes
are also on the rise
and some of these people are are
suggesting that
this is because of anti-asian sentiments
in the aftermath of coven
but some of it is not about that
presumably some of this
may just be about people who don't have
jobs who are who are now home doing bad
things to other people
but again the way that the media have
decided to treat this is though
is that is is so is that american
whiteness american white supremacy is
responsible for this increase
in anti-asian american sentiment and
they're going to use this latest
shooting in atlanta
in order to push forward that narrative
the shooting is an act of evil no matter
what okay the guy who committed the
shooting is a piece of crap
who should be executed okay the person
killed people
should go to death row should be
executed and if the person is white
supremacist
that is a good indicator that white
supremacy like actual honest to god
white supremacy
is evil but that's not the case that the
media would like to make
the media would like to make the case
that america more broadly is responsible
for all of this
anti-asian hate only matters under
certain circumstances for the media
not two weeks ago yahoo news ran a piece
titled anti-asian violence has been
rampant
here's why it's not always a hate crime
it's a mystery
why wait wait till you hear why they say
some anti-asian violence is not a hate
crime we'll get to this in just one
second first
spring is springing as we speak it is
the perfect reminder to tidy up and get
your life in order why not start by
protecting your family with life
insurance
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place and save 50
or more once you find your best option
the policy genius team will set up your
new policy for you and answer any
questions you have along the way
here's how you can get started first you
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
to find your best price policy genius
makes it easy to compare policies from
as little as 15 bucks a month
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
since their license stations work for
you not the insurance companies there is
zero hassle if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
policy genius will take care of
everything that kind of services earn
policy genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased device
all totally free to use so while you're
tidying up around the house this spring
why not get your life insurance
organized as well you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes feel good
knowing if something happens your loved
ones will be taken care of go to
policygenius.com to get started right
now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right okay so yahoo news
talks about anti-asian violence and they
say it's not always a hate crime
why is not always a hate crime because
it depends on who does it
and according to yahoo news as the
recent wave of attacks on older asian
americans prompts calls for action and
activism
experts urge the use of precise accurate
language in discussing the violence
weird how all of the urges to use
precise and accurate language and
describing the violence have gone
completely out the window
the moment you have a story or the media
are seeking to suggest that whiteness
more broadly is responsible for
anti-asian violence
the robberies and assaults in several
big city chinatowns have led to
significant media coverage and outcry
from activists many of whom have labeled
the incident's hate crimes
but recent higher profile cases that
have gone viral on social media aren't
being investigated as such
law enforcement officials say officials
say the occurrences don't show signs of
being racially motivated
well you know what's an incident that
doesn't show signs yet of being racially
motivated is this latest one in atlanta
that's not stopping the media
social media posts have conflated
violence against people who are asian
american with hate crimes against the
community at large
tying the crimes to pandemic related
racism some sources have declared a
spike in hate crimes citing an
astronomical increase but the figure
they refer to
specifically reflects new york city and
new york police data obtained by nbc
asian america which showed three
anti-asian hate crimes in 2019 and 28
last year
no hate crimes were reported this year
so far other sources refer to 18
incidents this year involving asian
americans in alameda county
california but local law enforcement
said there's no proof any of them
have been racially motivated in san
francisco six hate crimes were reported
in 2019 nine the following year
in 2021 the city reported one hate crime
not all cities reflected increases
washington dc reported a decrease
okay but where exactly why why exactly
is
is the media now getting sensitive about
anti-asian hate crime reporting
because there was a spate of videos that
came out that showed
a that showed unfortunately black
americans victimizing asian americans
and so as soon as those videos hit the
internet you started to see articles
crop up
about how this isn't really anti-asian
animus it's just sort of normal crime
that that is if a hate crime is a hate
crime then hate crime is hate crime
racism can come from any end of the
spectrum but you have to understand that
according to
leftist worldview it cannot come from
any end of the spectrum
see racism is only capable of being
attributed to white people
because it has to be white people
because white people have power and
racism without power is not racism this
is something we have learned
from the racist left the the reason that
this matters to the left is because the
left only treats asian americans
as a victimized minority sometimes in
the same way they only treat jews as
victimized minority
sometimes when a jew in williamsburg has
the hell beat out of him
by a black guy on the street that is not
considered a hate crime by folks on the
left
when did you get shot at the free of
life synagogue by white supremacist this
is a hate crime
according to the left now in my view
both are hate crimes
hey first of all i i have some rather
serious legal objections to the
terminology of hate crime and of
themselves because all crimes in in
essence are motivated by hate and
disregard for the humanity of the other
person you're committing a crime against
but so long as we are having a category
called hate crime the the guy walking
down the street
in a yamaka who has the crap beat out of
him by a guy walking down the street
who happens to be black that's that's
just as much of a hate crime as somebody
doing that if they were a white
supremacist but not according
to our wonderful wonderful media and
this is why you see
folks like ibram kendy tweeting out
about these
about these hate crimes he tweeted out
locking arms with asian americans facing
this lethal struggle
and facing this legal lethal wave of
anti-asian terror their struggle is my
struggle
our struggle is against racism and white
supremacist domestic terror oh is
is that what's happening here so you
guys are struggling against exactly the
same thing
interesting interesting take abram ex
candy
i i particularly liked the take from liz
plank
feminist ambulance she tweeted white
masculinity fetishizes and dehumanizes
asian women and is intrinsically
tied to racism it's crucial we don't
erase the way that misogyny and racism
operate together to justify killing
asian women
so you see even if there's no proof in
this particular case that this evil
piece of crap who committed the shooting
actually was anti-asian we can still say
that it's anti-asian white supremacy
without any evidence
at all now here's the thing they're
wildly inconsistent
on the left as to exactly when asians
ought to be treated as a victimized
minority and when they ought not to be
treated as a victimized minority
let's take for example the wonderful and
brilliant nicole hannah jones the de
facto editor-in-chief of the new york
times so nicole hannah jones who's the
creator of the garbage 1619 project the
fictionalized history of the united
states
on august 13th of last year she tweeted
out quote most asian americans arrived
in this country after the end of legal
segregation and discrimination
thanks to the black resistance struggle
yale has direct ties to slavery
further the doj is not going after the
segregated and unequal schools that
black children attend this was
her objecting to the fact that trump's
doj had gone after yale
for openly discriminating against asian
americans see the left
is fine with anti-asian hate so long as
it's directed at prospective college
students
they are fine with anti-asian hate so
long as it's directed at high achieving
kids
in merit-based public high schools
nicole hannah jones said
i did not say no asian people immigrated
here prior to 65. i said most in this
country did not because of the chinese
exclusion act and a racist
immigration quota system that means most
present-day asian-americans did not
experience legal discrimination here
right so in other words asian-americans
are not a victimized minority in nicole
hannah jones's view
but as soon as there is a shooting and
they can tie this to
in some way without any evidence white
supremacy then nicole hannah jones
tweets out even as this country was
recruiting chinese men to come to the
labor white workers would not they
barred chinese women from entering the
us in order to ensure the men would not
settle and start families in america so
now they're a victimized minority so
here's the thing
asian americans were historically a
victimized minority they've also
taken advantage of the fact that
america's wonderful meritocracy to
become
the most successful subgroup in american
life economically speaking these two
things are not mutually exclusive
asian americans did not stop being the
victims of hate simply because they are
economically successful and more than
jews stop being the victims of hate
because they were economically
successful but according to the left
these two things are mutually exclusive
so essentially a a
light wave basically asian americans and
jewish americans
are like the light waves of physics are
they a wave or are they a particle
it completely depends on the lens with
which you view them
if a white person victimizes a jew or
victimized an asian american then
they're a victimized minority if
those people are being victimized by
either a racist admissions system
or by black americans or by any other
minority americans then
those people are part of the of the
overgroup then they are part of the
white american superstructure
the the inconsistency is is essentially
i mean it's mind-blowing but it is
perfectly predictable
and again this is part of a broader
agenda and part of the broader agenda
is to suggest that the system itself is
responsible for anti-asian
hate crimes and something bad happens to
an asian that's because of america when
something bad happens to a jew that's
because of because of america
unless the person who happens to be
victimizing an asian or jew
is not a white person in which case it's
just sort of a random thing that
happened
and we don't really pay too much
attention to that because it doesn't
support the narrative
again none of this is not a single word
i've said here sit down and play the
specific evil that was done in lantern
we still don't know the motive and if it
turns out the guy was white supremacist
then we should blame white supremacy but
otherwise it's gonna be kind of hard to
prove that white supremacy is
responsible for the crime when you don't
have evidence of that
well the the joe while joe biden is
saying that he is going to hold off
on attributing motive in this particular
shooting john sackey is not
jen zaki is simply saying that without
evidence trump saying chinese virus is
what spurred this wave of hate crimes
again i've yet to be made aware
of exactly the motivations of people who
have or even the race of the people who
have been committing these hate crimes
against asian americans over the course
of the last year but that's not stopping
jen saki
is of no consequence here i think
there's no question
that uh some of the damaging rhetoric
that we saw
during the prior administration uh
blaming uh
you know calling covid uh you know the
wuhan virus or other things
led to you know perceptions
of the asian-american community that are
inaccurate unfair
have raised you know threatening
has elevated threats against uh asian
americans and
we're seeing that uh around the country
okay kamala harris is saying the same
thing she's saying we stand with you in
the face of anti-asian hate crimes
they don't stand with asian americans
when it comes to whether your kids can
go to school
but they're definitely standing with you
now now that they can suggest that it's
america
broadly that is racist against asian
americans just not we who specifically
are discriminating against asian
americans here is kamala harris the vice
president
i do want to say to our asian american
community that we stand with you and
understand
how this has frightened and shocked and
outraged
all people but knowing the the
increasing level of hate crime against
our asian american
brothers and sisters we also want to
speak out in
solidarity with them and and acknowledge
that none of us should ever
be silent in the face of any form of
hate you should definitely not be silent
in the form of discrimination
against any form of discrimination
against asian americans like say for
example the colleges were overtly
discriminating against asian americans
and not allowing them in because they
were performing too well on standardized
tests
then you definitely want to stand up and
say something about it wouldn't you
quote
biden doj drops a lawsuit claiming yale
discriminates against white nation
students
this february 2021. the department of
justice on wednesday dropped a trump-era
lawsuit
alleging yale university discriminated
against white and asian applicants
backing away from former president
trump's fight against college
affirmative action policies the
this is according to forbes the doj
filed a request to dismiss in federal
court in connecticut
effectively ending a four-month-old
legal gambit claiming yale's admissions
officers disadvantaged white nation
students by placing too much weight on
applicants race
a doj spokesperson told forbes its
decision was made in light of all
available facts circumstances and legal
developments
federal officials will continue a
three-year-old investigation into yale's
admissions practices they are no longer
alleging the school broke civil rights
laws
at all so totally fine for yale to
discriminate against asian students
meanwhile same week back in february the
san francisco school board voted to end
merit-based admissions at lowell high
they moved the school into a lottery
system why did they do that because too
many asian americans
based on merit were getting into lowell
high
according to kgo on tuesday night san
francisco's board of education voted to
end the merit-based admission at lowell
a top academic high school the issue has
been an emotional lightning rod within
the district lowell's alumni community
residents of san francisco the bay area
and beyond the vote followed hours of
public comment and discussion via zoom
the vote was five to two in favor of
changing lowell's admission policy
in october because of the pandemic the
san francisco school board proposed
eliminating selective merit-based
admission at lowell for one school year
when racist incidents resurfaced at the
high school last month the board quickly
proposed a resolution to make the change
permanent
at the according to california school
dashboard 50 of the students at lowell
again because it's a merit-based are
asian
18 percent are white 12 percent latino 2
african-american
so what did they decide to do they
decided too many asians here got to stop
it
and so they moved out they moved against
it meanwhile in new york city mayor bill
de blasio has been moving for years to
stop
asians from getting into new york city's
elite high schools in fact
his plan was to basically shut down high
schools rather than allow there to be
elite high schools at which asian
americans were overrepresented
so active discrimination active
discrimination against asian americans
is a core part of the democratic
platform
that seems like anti-asian hate to me
frankly if you're saying that a person
can't get into school
because they are performing too well
because they don't have the right race
that is anti-asian discrimination that
is anti-asian hate
it's a lot more hateful frankly than
suggesting that a virus that came from
china is in fact a chinese virus
okay but according to the left racism
against asian americans is fine so long
as it comports with their agenda
and it is not fine when they are allowed
to use it as a brick bat with which to
club the united states more broadly
which is how you end up with pieces like
this one
from the root okay there's a guy named
damon young
it's an insane piece he wrote he wrote
this piece yesterday
whiteness is a pandemic quote
i don't have much to add here today that
hasn't already been said whiteness is a
public health crisis
whiteness remember this is not about
white supremacy
like in its classic definition anymore
this is not about why people believing
they are superior to other races
whiteness itself is a pandemic it
shortens life expectancies it pollutes
air it constricts equilibrium it
devastates force it melts ice caps it
sparks and funds wars it flattens
dialects it infests consciousnesses
and it kills people white people and
people who are not white my mom included
there will be people who die in 2050
because of white supremacy induced
decisions from 1850
the whole system has to be torn down and
it doesn't matter whether you can
actually identify the white supremacy in
any particular incident
everything bad that happens on planet
earth is due to whiteness
all of it is due to whiteness because
whiteness is buried in the
superstructure
whiteness is at the root of the tree
that is the civilization
and so every bad fruit of that tree is
because the root itself is rotten
a lion cannon should be drawn from the
actions of the white supremacists who
walked into three atlanta area massage
parlors yesterday
and allegedly killed eight people six of
whom were of asian descent to the
relentless
anti-asian rhetoric pollinating national
discourse over the past year
based on based on what damon young
are you gonna provide any evidence of
this the former president and the party
of the former president canon should be
blamed for this
and the sudden increase of racist
violence against asian americans the
line doesn't stop there
it extends back 400 years and has
tentacles clawing everywhere white
supremacists
white supremacy exists here in america
which is everywhere
there's a line connecting this act of
terror to the 11 people killed at the
tree of life synagogue in 2018
the nine people killed at the emanuel
african methodist episcopal church in
2015 of course
well first of all you'd have to show the
evidence of that those were actual
overtly white supremacist acts of
terrorism
we don't know the answer on this one it
may be but we don't know that yet
in fact there was a tweet yesterday that
was that was particularly illuminating
i believe it was from ibram kendy and
his suggestion was
that it does not matter i'm sorry not it
was not emotion candy it was michael
harriet
who also writes for the root he tweeted
quote there will never be any data that
says racial violence is because of white
supremacy
because most white supremacists don't
think they are white supremacists
so in other words we don't actually have
to prove white supremacy at any point
we don't even have to listen to the
motivations of people who are who are
who are committing these acts
all we have to do is just attribute
white supremacy to them because they
don't know their own minds that is
complete unfalsifiable nonsense
just absolutely unfalsifiable nonsense
but that of course is the point
so back to this piece from this writer
damon young
at the root that i just have to read to
the end of this piece
white supremacy is a virus that like
other viruses will not die until there
are no bodies left for it to infect
which means the only way to stop it is
to locate it isolate it extract it and
kill it
i guess a vaccine could work too but
we've had 400 years to develop one
so i won't hold my breath i don't even
know what the hell that is supposed to
mean this is a contributing opinion
writer for the new york times
i do not understand what that is
supposed to mean there are no more
bodies left
i mean are you talking about killing
white people like what ex i honestly got
i don't know what that means maybe it
doesn't mean that but
i read to you verbatim that paragraph i
don't know what it means here is what i
do know
what i do know is that the left does not
give two dams about anti-asian
discrimination
in education they don't care about
anti-asian discrimination in the
workplace they don't care about
anti-discrimination in virtually every
area of life where asians are considered
part of the broad white majority because
they are quote unquote too successful
they don't care about asians who are
beat up by particular members of
particular races
they only care about anti-asian hate
when it becomes a convenient point
for them to try and plant the notion
that america is
is a white supremacist country by the
way if america is such a terribly white
supremacist country
one indicator is not a particular white
overall would be that the single
greatest economically performing
subgroup in america are asian americans
okay so none of this makes any sense but
again it doesn't have to make sense
any any club that can be wielded against
the foundational
ideas of america the meritocracy the
the freedoms of america any idea that
can be wielded against that any incident
without evidence that can be wielded
against that
that can be attributed to quote-unquote
whiteness and whiteness means all the
institutions
according to the left not according to
me i'm not a racist so i don't think
that our institutions are quote-unquote
white
i don't think that freedom is a white
idea i don't think that it's a
i think freedom is a civilized idea i
don't think individual rights are a
white idea
okay only the left thinks that crap but
what the left is trying to do as
always is have it both ways they always
want it both ways there's only one
there's one set of rules that applies to
people who are
higher ranking on the intersectional
hierarchy who get apparently to
victimize asian americans whenever they
want
and then there is a second set of rules
that applies to a society that is not
even responsible for
this particular act or for an
independent white supremacist movement
an actual white supremacist
movement that commits acts of evil at
every available turn against the same
way they treat anti-semitism
the way they treat anti-semitism is it
only exists if you can try to plant it
on the right meanwhile we will back
every antisemite we can find in congress
as long as they have a dnx to their name
that's the way this works it's cynical
and it's gross and it does not fight
hate and it does not mitigate against
hate
if we're not fighting all hate the same
way then you're not actually fighting
hate are you
in just a second we'll get to how this
is now infusing
our government how it has infused our
culture this this basic
theory that that america is a racist
country
and all sins can be attributed to that
racist country but we must never
attribute
sinfulness or or racism to individuals
who are
of victimized heritage in the united
states we'll get to that in just one
moment first
fellas the sport of business means
demanding excellence from your craft and
wardrobe your fits
need to be versatile we're talking about
blending timeless style and comfort so
you look as good as you feel for that
there's cuts of clothing let me just
tell you i only wear cuts t-shirts
they've taken a classic men's fashion
staple the plain tee they've refined it
combining premium quality with a
minimalist aesthetic
cuts shirts polos hoodies crew
sweatshirts they're made for the man who
works hard
plays hard and never settles for less
all in the sport of business they're
built for performance in the boardroom
the bar or the gym
cuts clothing keeps you sharp wherever
the game takes you take a plain tee make
it tony stark the bleeding edge of
fabric technology meets the man
confident enough to wear it
cut it's the perfect t-shirt next cuts
is set out to create fabric uniquely
engineered for each clothing style
they've got the new cuts hoodie they
developed hyperloop french terry fabric
a textile that is temperature controlled
and
ageless as well you're not gonna need to
take it off you certainly won't want to
it is excellent or
try the wrinkle-free pika polo a design
that keeps
you fitted for the office the golf
course at home the gym or your next hot
date cuts is premium with a purpose
again i only wear
cuts clothing when i'm wearing a t-shirt
it is not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing it's office leisure apparel for
the sport of business get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
shapiro that is cutsclothing.com shapiro
for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing go
check them out right now okay we're
going to get into more of this
how critical race theory which is really
what we're talking about here
that racism only counts sometimes and it
depends on who is doing it the racism
and the evidence required for racism the
standard of evidence changes radically
depending on who you can blame
for the alleged racism we'll get to that
in just one moment first there is a buzz
in the air here at the daily wire
candace owns filmed the first episode of
her brand new show yesterday it's all
anyone in the office can talk about this
morning
it looks spectacular candace is great
folks you're going to love it
it is unlike any other daily wire show
that you've ever seen before
candace premieres tomorrow if you want a
sneak peek of her new show
and why wouldn't you join candace owens
and the rest of the daily water gang
tonight for a special edition of
backstage we're going to discuss
candace's new show
as well as the big picture issues
affecting our nation joe biden's
terrifying accomplishments
cardi b's incredible profound grammy
performance join candace and the rest of
the crew live
at 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m here in nashville
at dailywire.com or the dailywire
youtube channel to be part
of the conversation and do not forget
candace premieres tomorrow
it is exclusive to daily wear members
it's not available to everybody in the
world
you have to be a member you're going to
want to see it it is awesome if you
aren't a member yet be sure to join now
make sure you don't miss a single
episode of canvas go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas for 25 off
that is dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace get 25 off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
this theory of the united states that
the united states is deeply racist
therefore if a white person in the
united states does
an indubitably bad thing it must be
attributable to racism without any
evidence you're not trying to show the
evidence it can just be attributed to
the system more broadly not even to
specific white supremacist beliefs
butts of the system more broadly but
that if an asian is beat up by a black
person on the streets of new york that
that does not count as a hate crime
because
racism only counts as sometimes or it's
not racism or even if that does happen
that in and of itself is attributable to
the system in which people live
and therefore it's still whiteness to
blame this sort of mentality has now
infused all areas of our government when
joe biden talks about equity
in american government this is what he
is talking about this is why today
emily's an audie reporting at the daily
wire the state department is quote
unquote racing to address 232 year old
problem of quote unquote entrenched
whiteness
do you notice how the terminology has
changed here right we went from
like virtually all terms in american
politics
we now have laundering of language right
so it starts off as white supremacy
white supremacy is rooted in white
supremacism right it's rooted
in the idea that white people are
inherently superior
to other races then people decided that
that wasn't enough because that didn't
apply to a broad enough class of people
you couldn't indict the entire system
with that because the vast majority of
americans don't believe that crap
so instead they said white supremacy
just means the system
then people are like yeah but that
doesn't sound like white supremacy that
just sounds like the system so they said
whiteness
so now whiteness is the problem which
sounds super racist right
whiteness is the problem imagine if
someone said blackness is the problem
and you understand just how racist that
is off the tip of your tongue right
but according to our entire government
now whiteness is the problem
so according to the daily wire the
department of defense is not the only
cabinet level agency undergoing a woke
makeover according to politico
the state department is also wrestling
with its identity and quote unquote
racing
to address a 232-year history of quote
unquote entrenched whiteness
according to politico anthony blinken's
state department is racing to address a
232 year old problem the overwhelming
and entrenched whiteness
of the nation's oldest government agency
the department's 23 000 or so american
staff may be the global face of america
but they don't look like it
and the gap is growing not shrinking by
many metrics the 40
of the american population is from a
racial or ethnic minority only 13
percent of the department's senior
executive service are people of color
said ambassador gina abercrombie wins
stanley a career diplomat
it was more diverse in 1986 literally
than it is now says eric rubin president
of the american foreign services
association which represents the
department's diplomats according to
politico president joe biden has pledged
to run the most diverse government ever
that involves rethinking and
reformatting
some of the most significant
governmental institutions
lincoln has submitted a report on the
state department's diversity and
inclusion
program now can they name a procedure
inside the state department that is
overtly discriminating against non-white
people
i have significant doubts they can
because that violates the civil rights
act of 1965.
so instead they are simply saying that
it is discriminatory
on the basis that there are not enough
members of particular races in
particular positions which inherently
means because this is a zero-sum game
there's only one person who can get each
job
what that means is that they're going to
people who will be people who are left
out of the job
on the basis not of merit but on the
basis of race which is in fact racial
discrimination
this is the same logic that is used by
the left when it comes to college
admissions it's the reason they're
shutting down high schools because
they're a quote unquote too many asians
although the report was focused on the
agency's issues it also proposed
solutions including hiring a chief
diversity and inclusion officer yes this
always solves the problem to quote
unquote
advance and align dni policies across
the department bring transparency to
these initiatives and hold senior
leadership accountable on progress
the state department is committed to
educating its workforce on anti-racism
remember anti-racism is the garbage
robin d'angelo ibram kennedy philosophy
that suggests
that any institution that results in
non-equal outcomes by racial group
is inherently racist and must be torn to
the ground
it is not about whether equal
opportunity has been provided it is not
about meritocracy meritocracy is itself
racist according to these same folks
the state department gave an
announcement they scheduled an
instructional zoom stressing the idea
that racism is a threat to national
security
the event titled racism being a threat
to national security and democracy
featured a range of progressive speakers
including former democratic
representative tom perriello who
currently serves as executive director
for george soros's open society
foundation
and center for constitutional rights
attorney diala shamus and western state
center executive director eric ward
secretary blinken has made it 100 clear
he's committed to diversity equity and
inclusion
and again these are code words for we
get to be as racist as we want to be so
long
as what we are attempting to do is do
this work on behalf
of only particular minority groups in
the united states
i promise you that if there is an
outsized surge of asian americans in the
state department that is not going to be
counted by the biden administration as
sufficiently diverse
this has infused our government this
ideology has infused our corporations
deloitte and touch has now told
employees that microaggressions are a
punishable offense
according to daily wire during a
mandatory anti-racism training u.s
employees at deloitte were introduced to
the company's new quote-unquote
anti-racist culture
employees were told they are expected to
help cultivate the quote unquote
anti-racist culture
when working with personnel and clients
and to promote equity
how is equity defined quote the outcome
of diversity inclusion and
anti-oppression
wherein all people have fair access
opportunity resources and power
so why is equity different from equality
because equality doesn't take into
account the historical and systemic
barriers and privileges of certain
racial groups which is of course the
point right the idea here is that if you
provide equal opportunity that doesn't
take into account historic
discrimination
because of historic discrimination we
have to discriminate in the here and now
this is the
iberian kennedy has said this right he
says discrimination in the past can only
be remedied by discrimination today
and discrimination today can only be
remedied by discrimination tomorrow
discrimination forever you might say
employees at the
were told that violation of deloitte's
policies could extend to
microaggressions
and all u.s offices are to investigate
violations of anti-racist policies you
don't have to be a racist
if you're just not anti-racist meaning
you don't believe that all of america's
systems
are racist that meritocracy you believe
is not racist or individual
rights are not racist this means you may
have violated corporate policy over at
deloitte
this ideology has infused all of
american government it's infused
corporate america
it is poisonous it is disgusting okay
this ideology
uh the the the supposed anti-racist
ideology which in fact divides us by
race and then talks about racial
essentialism and then suggests
that we have to discriminate we must
discriminate on the basis of race
that causes more hatred it causes more
division
meanwhile these same racist leftists it
is racism these same racist leftists
are turning around and attributing to
all of american society
racism when an incident occurs that may
or may not have been a racist incident
and it still has nothing to do with
mainstream american society
pretty incredible how this works so it
seems that the term racist according to
the left is a completely fungible one
sometimes it is completely inapplicable
just when they decide that it's not
applicable and sometimes it is not only
applicable it is a
brick to hurl through whatever window is
convenient to hurl the brick through
today and well i am going to give a
shout out here
to uh the best governor in america my
home state governor ron desantis in
florida
ron desantis announced yesterday that
florida is not going to allow this kind
of crappy theory to be taught
in public schools in the state of
florida here was governor desantis
yesterday
florida civics curriculum will
incorporate foundational concepts
with the best materials and it will
expressly exclude
unsanctioned narratives like critical
race theory and other
unsubstantiated theories let me be clear
there's no room
in our classrooms for things like
critical race theory
teaching kids to hate their country and
to hate each other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
and good for governor ron desantis who
absolutely is right on this
what you're going to see is the country
breaks down is that you're going to see
these theories taught in california but
not in florida it's just going to
exacerbate the national polarization
and divide alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime be sure to check
out the matt wall show which airs at 1
30 pm eastern over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show